well it's so common that you barely
notice it but the biggest companies in
the country discriminate openly against
their employees on the basis of skin
color they call that equity it's racism
but it's everywhere it's illegal
what's changing is that some employees
are now fighting back brian netzel who
worked for a decade at amex until he was
fired in 2020 just filed a class-action
lawsuit against the company he says that
american express quote gave preferential
treatment to individuals for being black
and unambiguous unambiguously signaled
to white employees that their race was
an impediment to getting ahead in the
company again that's happening
everywhere
and here's someone who's taking it to
court
david torak is the lawyer in this case
he represents netsil and he joins us
tonight mr pifter thanks so much for
joining us so
i'm not a lawyer but it does seem that
this is unambiguously
illegal correct
absolutely tucker it's it's unlawful
it's been illegal since at least the
1960s since the passage of the civil
rights act
but um you know the reason that this is
happening is because you know back in
the summer of saint floyd in 2020
a lot of these corporations they saw
that you know the blm writers were
allowed to burn down entire cities with
absolutely zero consequences because it
was in the name of social justice so why
wouldn't the companies be emboldened to
treat their white employees like
second-class citizens violate the most
fundamental
civil rights laws in this country when
we see this precedent that was happening
for several years now
companies want to do all kinds of crazy
things but then the us government pushes
them back within the bounds of the law
that's why we have a justice department
which has a civil rights division whose
whole purpose is to prevent racial
discrimination in the workplace have
they said anything about this
absolutely not um you know we filed a
complaint with the equal employment
opportunity commission which is the
administrative arm of the government
that's supposed to be handling stuff
like this and go after companies like
american express like
a lot of these companies um like
like uber and chase and a lot of these
other other companies that are uh
instigating these policies but um they
just don't enforce it uh because again
it's done in the name of quote social
justice
they think it's
benign discrimination which
you know the late justice scalia said is
never the case
yeah well racism is always wrong no
matter who's being hurt by it and this
as wrong in this case as it ever was in
any other case and so we're certainly
rooting for you to prevail i appreciate
coming on tonight david
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight